hey wassup guys my name is a Jenner and
welcome to episode 104 of game
programming so today we're gonna take a
look at multiple targeting for our dual
our little shooter mob here so basically
what's going on is if you guys watch the
last episode which you should have
episode hundred and three you would have
seen that we have this mob here called
shooter that essentially just walks
around randomly and the reason it's even
called shooters because it can see it
just constantly shoots this this
projectile at us just in a line as you
can see wherever we move wherever it
moves whatever it just shoots it in the
direction of us and of course that is
the collision not really working out but
the idea is that it always shoots us so
now what we want to do is kind of give
it the ability to pick its targets okay
so in that case of course we were the
only target but what if there were other
mobs around or what if there were other
players around right in realm of the mad
God some I guess monsters which have the
ability to actually directly find not
just randomly fire they will fire at
potentially you know the closest player
or at least a random player right they
won't fire at just just the one player
they won't just fire at one player that
would be stupid be ridiculous unless
maybe that was a feature of of them
initially picks a player and it just
does not let go of that player but the
idea is we want to kind of give it the
ability to expand so what we are what we
want to do first is in this utility
folder that we have here we've got our
vector class right and that's not that's
just beautiful so now what we kind of
want to do is maybe find out the
distance between two vectors okay we
haven't actually done that yet so what
we might want to do in vector is put
something along the lines of maybe
double public double and then something
like get distance yeah and the distance
would be between two vectors right so
vector 2i I guess vector 0 and vector 2i
back to 1 okay and now here we would
just calculate the distance again the
distance of course is very very simple
to calculate it's a bit of pipe I Thakur
I'm right so all we need to do there is
let's just quickly
get us out so we've got our I guess
what's the best way to go that's where
all the obstacle X right the horizontal
distance and that's just V zero dot get
X minus v1 dot get X and then we've got
the same of course coming on for y and
then we essentially just compute the
distance so we can just write away
return x times X plus y times y all
right and that would be it of course
wouldn't we do need a square at that but
um that's it right I'm honestly don't
like that we don't even need this
distance variable but yeah okay so
that's kind of how we're doing it that's
a way to do it okay and that would work
out the absolute distance right that's
not no there are other algorithms like
such as the Manhattan distance and all
these all the all these are the crazy
algorithms but this is just the line of
sight distance right that's the direct
like diagonal kind of line distance okay
and the reason I think that's probably
the best one to use here is because um I
mean it's a bullet right we're shooting
a projectile so we can shoot a
projectile directly okay if it was
something like moving we might want to
make it not move diagonally so Delta we
might we might use something like
Manhattan distance to compute the
distance okay because Manhattan distance
basically just ignores diagonals right
so Manhattan distance would simply be X
plus y it's kind of it's pretty much
that simple right because you imagine
imagine if better than that imagine if
um if you have something along the lines
of one entity you know over here one
entity over here the distance that we've
kind of computer right now is just that
distance and let me just is there a
straight line tool because that would be
really useful actually if you think that
probably is yeah here we go that's the
distance that we've computed but
Manhattan distance oops
I want you to stay seal right can you
just oh my goodness I need to learn how
to use paint on that all right but what
the other thing that that's that's
that's I guess the direct distance right
but if we wanted to figure out like the
Manhattan
since for example that would actually be
that Plus that my goodness that Plus
that right and obviously that would
ignore diagonals but what I want to
emphasize that we worked at way of kind
of calculated the exact distance and you
guys should have remembered this from
the previous tutorial of course but just
in case you didn't that's a quick
refresh ok so all that does is return
the distance now now that we've got that
we have a way to kind of figure out
whether our you know I guess which mob
is closer to the shooter ok because the
shooter is going to be able to pick out
right now we'll just make it so that it
picks a random no sorry no random so
that it just picks the closest mob and
it fires at the closest mob ok so to do
that first of all let's not only get the
client Slayer right let's um let's also
get every entity so we'll get a list of
entities right and the list of entities
which we'll call entities will just be
in the level plus we have a method
called get players which we could use by
the way if we wanted our monsters to
target players which we probably would
right if we were kind of working for a
realm of the mad God type thing we would
want our shooter or or at least our
monsters to target only players we
wouldn't want them to shoot each other I
guess so
get players right would return every
single player in a radius ok and then it
could pick random random or by some
criteria targets from this because it
has access to the actual player class of
that player something like get entities
though for us right now because we don't
have we don't have any other players and
we want to see this working we can use
something like level get entities right
and now we'll just simply return this
and we'll say a radius of maybe about 50
ok again I keep getting the distances
make sure you put the utili snot the
abstract window toolkit list and we're
gonna have to see if goes all right so
now that we've got these two things you
guys might be like well what about this
player right and the thing is we do kind
of want to put this player into
consideration all right we don't want to
the players separately we want to just
kind of add it to the list and remember
the player is actually an entity so
something like that is perfectly
perfectly acceptable and in fact what
we'll actually do is we'll just go
entities don't add level don't get climb
player okay and that should be the
bracket okay simple as that and what
we've kind of done here is we've we've
we've put the player into this entities
list manually okay and now we can figure
out a bunch of things here so this is
actually the direction of shooting and
stuff like that but what we want to do
now though and this is important right
before we figure out the direction which
is a sample which is an absolute
different debate by itself we want to UM
actually figure out which entity we want
to shoot at okay so let's go ahead and
what's up here sorry what am I done
and she's dot we will copy this their
entities I've been talking and I kind of
dismiss that whole thing okay so we'll
get NC equals entities or get I'm all
right
and what we're going to do is we want to
kind of figure out the distances but we
don't just want to figure out the
distances we want to figure out a
specific distance right we want to set a
minimum distance so double men which
will stand for minimum distance which
will be zero okay and we want to see if
there's anything kind of well there
won't be anything Alton that but okay
you know I'm just going to shut up for a
minute and you guys will see so what
we're doing here is we're getting the
entity in the ArrayList we now want to
compare the the distance here so double
distance is going to equal vector 2i
this should be a static method by the
way it either should be a static static
method or you could you could make one
of them not a parameter and make one of
them implied but just for the process of
this will make it static alright so
vectors who I don't get distance and
what you got what you guys will see
later is will probably make a vector
class that is a superclass
okay and then it will have methods like
that so that because basically what I'm
saying is this method can get applied to
any vector not just vector 2i so when we
add if we add stuff like back to 2d or
back to 2f we don't want to copy and
paste this method okay but that's in the
future something on top of that now okay
this is dragging on is enough I'm sorry
but the first vector here will be um our
position vector so basically what I'll
do eventually is I'll just um X&Y right
what I'll do eventually is I'll probably
just make make positions back to two
eyes instead of X and wire just because
probably they're simpler okay great um
and then we'll do for this one a dot get
X you don't get Y so that's a pretty
long line of code it's a distance so
vector two I don't get distance from our
vector so that's the vector that's the
position of the shooter and then this
vector which is the vector of the
current entity that we've gotten inside
the follow and what we want to do is
want to set minimum equal to that
distance all right we'll only do that if
either I is zero because we have to for
the first time otherwise is it just
going to be zero or we'll set that if
I'm just making this up on the spot by
the way but we'll also set that if if
this distance is actually less than
minimum all right
so if we found a new minimum we want to
set it okay otherwise that's it and
we'll do that for every single entity so
now we figured out what entity we have
as the minimum okay so we've figured out
a minimum distance that's one thing
right one thing that probably is a
better thing to do though well we'll
have to do it anyway is will actually
find our closest entity so entity
closest right now is null okay
so again with these arguments
minimum is going to equal distance
that's correct but we'll also set
closest equal to e all right and then
write what we can do then is change this
to e and we can figure out a little
thing here and sorry not a closest
change that to closest and then we can
figure out our direction and then we'll
do all this stuff
only if closest doesn't equal null so if
there are no entities within a radius of
30 then it's not going to shoot okay
remember the player will still shoot so
our radius 150 to play a little to shoot
because it's not an irradiance okay but
um we'll figure that case out separately
if we need to okay so if we run what
should happen now is the exact same as
before right
it should shoot at us and it's actually
shooting in a bit of a different angle
which is a bit weird so let's just
figure that out quickly all right so the
reason that it's actually picking up
closest is because we never told it to
explode itself now that's one of the
things that is pretty important so in
sidearm leveled like get entities right
what will you join as we've said get a
bunch of entities that are within a
radius of a given entity which will
include the given entity right because
the given entity is as far as its
concerned 0 from the position so what we
need to do is we want to stop it from
returning yourself because what's
happening here
is this actually returning itself and
the player and then it's saying okay
well the closest entity to me is me so
I'm gonna shoot at me okay I'm gonna
shoot it myself so that's what's been
happening so what we want to do to
change that is very very simple we want
to say that if entity here is actually
equal to e alright so if the anticipate
we've gotten is equal to e then just
disregard it continue okay don't
consider that entity as a valid fit do
not add it to result okay because it is
it's it's me okay don't even bother
doing the rest so that's very important
you could probably also do equals at
this point but it is always much safer
in Java to do dot equals okay and you
can always override that if it's not
giving you the result you want so that
is why I'm saying it's better because
there is no operator overloading in Java
well there is but you can't do it
yourself
so unfortunately there was really no
workaround for something like a equals
equals but there is four equals because
as a method great so let's let's not
dive into that complex stuff but now you
can see that he's shooting at us which
is wonderful so now let's kind of give
him a bit of a crash course let's go
let's go into our spawn level and to
test this thing whether it works on
intruder we've got a twenty fifty five
we've got a shooter okay wonderful
let's make him not move okay otherwise
it's gonna make it difficult to test
so just because he'll be moving all over
the place and we want to play is another
interesting it would be ridiculous so
we'll find our move method here and just
comment it out I don't know where it is
gonna have to just there it is all right
so I'll comment out the move method so
now he should still be shooting at us of
course but he's not moving
great fantastic so remember his position
is a 20 comma 20 20 comma 55 right 20:55
let's add oh we can add two shooters
later and I can shoe to each other but
let's add a dummy at let's say 15 15 52
or 50 and 53 not that it really matters
and we'll also go to dummy and make sure
the dummies don't move so where's the
move method here here it is and now
basically what I'm what I'm saying is
that instead of shooting at us he really
should should be shooting at this dummy
but he's not he's still shooting at us
so we need to go back to our shooter and
figure that out because that should have
worked
hmm I think the number one thing that I
probably could even think of is the fact
that um I mean shooting at us but I
think maybe that distance is just
greater than 50 because if it's in
pixels in each tile is like 16 that
might be 64 distance so let's turn this
up to like 500 all right I remember that
of course is the radius that is going to
acquire into spire and we'll see what
that well that gives us hopefully I'll
give us great okay so he's not shooting
it off so I'm assuming that he's
shooting out exactly okay so now he's
shooting at this guy and it's stopping
right before the the bullets explode
okay so with some I love how they're
trying to move but he's shooting at this
so what if we go closer up look at
he's gonna stop shooting it back on he's
gonna shout start shooting it out until
we go it out of range at which point so
he switches back to that guy look at
that fantastic all right so now now
let's bless let's place a bunch of
shooters around so we'll put another
shooter at maybe like 45 that might be
too far shouldn't be 48 and they should
be shooting each other okay so this
guy's shooting at me all right until I
go out of range see as soon as I got out
of range scum starting this guy and this
guy shooting at that guy cuz that guy's
closer to him and this guy isn't
shooting at anyone because he's not a
shooter okay so got this nice kind of
system going where he'll he'll do that
okay we could make him pick a random
target okay so we might do that next
episode um in fact we probably will
because picking a random target I think
is something that wrong with a man
called ulster so next episode which
should be later on this week we will
cover picking a random target
effectively and shooting it I'm not
picking a new target every update
because that would be stupid but
everybody like maybe a few seconds or if
something changed as we'll pick a new
random target and shoot at him or her
okay simple as that
so hope you guys have enjoyed this
episode of game programming if you have
please hit like button that's really all
I want from you guys it's it shows your
support more than anything else and
hopefully I'll see you guys very very
soon with episode 105 in which we will
cover a random target I guess picking
okay so if you do require help with this
episode if you didn't understand
something then the best place to get it
would be of course my forums so make
sure that you um make sure that you hit
up the Cherno comm which is right over
here
I always forget to open it so I have to
like open menu at the end of the video
but um if you go to forums then there's
a movie we actually hit a thousand posts
here and I mean this this farms really
early
active like really active so more active
than iron that's a sure
so um make sure you guys do go ahead and
register there if you haven't already
and you can post your your stuff into
here and you can see like you can see
just how active this is I mean look I'm
showing this entire page and it's all
been like the last post has been either
today or yesterday so it's active you
guys will get your questions answered
this one's even come for these replies
must be pretty uh pretty serious but
anyway that's it um hope you guys enjoy
the episode I'll see you guys next time
good bye
you